it may not look like it but the united
states is under attack
a suspected russian hacking campaign has
penetrated
top secret parts of the government
lawmakers want answers
the whole government should be all over
it it's a deeply
concerning deeply distressing and an
extreme challenge for our country this
this hack was so big
in scope that even our
cyber security experts don't have a real
sense yet
in terms of the breadth of
of the intrusion itself security
officials are scrambling to understand
the scope of an attack that started at
least nine months ago
the hackers used various ways to
compromise computer systems
one was through a piece of software
called orion made by the technology firm
solarwinds
malicious code was inserted into an
update for this software
used by thousands of customers once the
update was installed
the hackers had access to a trove of
networks
including into the us government and
microsoft
they could steal secrets change
important data
or just sit on systems spying it's one
of the most significant cyber attacks
really that's ever been seen based on
what we know at this point
it seems to be that sort of traditional
espionage
getting information from governments and
companies rather than
altering data destroying data tampering
with things and
and so forth but it remains to be seen
what the final picture tells us
russia is reported to be behind the hack
the president though through a spokesman
has denied any involvement
there's a real sense of concern here
about this hacking campaign
it's still going on and there's still
much to learn about who's been hit
from what we know so far it does seem
that the us was the main target
but a small number of british
organizations not in the public sector
are also known to have been compromised
silence on the breach from the outgoing
president still caught up in election
denial
his deputy focused on this country's
other big fight
but dealing with the cyber hack will be
a major task for their replacements
debra haynes sky news washington